hey everybody its Jesse and it's we're
going to start out today doing a going
over a pool request and I was just
testing it out so I've gotten pretty
much nothing done since yesterday so
we're gonna start right where we left
off that so yesterday after I ended I
just answer some emails talk to my boss
a little bit and then left this morning
I bet I've been in meetings all day so
there actually have been interviewing
someone for web developer position so we
did an interview like a panel interview
and then I just got back from doing a
technical interview it was kind of cool
because we actually used some free code
camp challenges for the technical
interview so I thought that was kind of
fun and I've heard that other people do
that as well so I don't know if it's a
widespread thing but hey you know if you
go through the free code camp challenges
then you got a shot at maybe seeing it
in an interview so might help you out
also I got a comment on one of my videos
saying that I should talk less and code
more and I was actually thinking the
same thing yesterday afternoon so I'm
gonna try to do that I can't guarantee
anything because as as you all know from
watching a I do tend to talk so I'm
gonna try to talk when I need to to
explain what's going on in the code and
then of course to answer questions but
other than that I am going to try to do
more code I
let's see was I gonna say oh okay I do
some silent streams on my own channel
occasionally so if you really would
rather just see the code and not worry
about my commentary on the code check
out those streams
I don't really schedule them too far in
advance I just kind of do it whenever I
have some time here and there throughout
the day so the best way to hear about
them
I usually tweet about them so if you
follow me on Twitter you'll probably see
the tweet or if you subscribe to my
channel you'll get an alert but those
are just like I said I don't schedule
them it'll just happen and I'll do it
until usually for like an hour or so
until something comes up at work and I
can't do it anymore alright so I'm gonna
say hi to everyone in the live chat and
I have some have some questions already
a question have you ever had a female
boss yeah I have so my my immediate
supervisor is a male and then the
director of my department and the
executive director of my department are
both women and I've worked for four
women before so not not really a big
deal to me okay also this video is going
to be shorter than normal so I told you
yesterday that I kept trying to go see
this guy's computer and about an issue
he's having with a website I made and
it's it's on campus here and I I haven't
been able to get a time it's the one
that I thought possibly might be using
Internet Explorer 9 so I got an email
back from him saying that he'll be there
around 4 p.m. so I'm not missing this
opportunity I have to know what is
really going on with this website he's
saying he gets a blank screen and
nothing
happens at all which is crazy so I want
to know so I definitely am gonna shoot
for like being over around like 3:30
Eastern Time
so maybe about an hour long stream I
could probably go a little bit longer
than that and still make it there but I
don't want to take any chances alright
so let me show you what's what's going
on here I'm working on this error
message right now so I have let's see
this sidebar item J s is giving me an
error no duplicate props allowed and I
got this because if you notice these are
now the same color which is awesome so
that was a a pool request that I got
from let me show you the pool request
where do I have it
okay so here's the pool request and
alright so there's a one in the name so
let me I think I I have a message on
Twitter from this person as well so okay
soul a late want I'm not I'm not really
sure I pronounce it but sent this pool
request
so if you're watching let me know how to
pronounce your name cuz I don't wanna
get it wrong so basically as it says it
customized the hover event okay so it
just ended up using if you remember
yesterday we were Sebastian was saying
it's the the list item that needs to get
the the hover but the list item was
being created by the I think it was the
menu item component yeah the menu item
component so we couldn't access it
directly so now let's just switch to
using the menu item directly and it
seems like everything works the same as
it did before so that's not exactly how
its said to do this side drawer and the
documentation but it works so I think
I'm gonna pull it in but before I pull
it in I tested it and I got that error
so I just want to work on that error
first and then pull this in to the
master branch and then we can continue
on with our layout for everybody that's
new joining I want to explain so if
you're joining from Twitter I had said
I'm using material UI and materialized
CSS which may be a little bit confusing
so we're using material UI and all the
nice react components that it has but
when there's a feature that it doesn't
have that I like from materialized then
I'm gonna pull that in so we've pulled
in the column classes already and we're
probably gonna pull in some other things
like I like how they they do they're
responsive font so we'll probably pull
that in and we'll
as we go along so we're gonna use a
blend of the two and I have started the
and rock server so let me I'm gonna
paste that link in for you all so you
can follow along and in case you can't
see the live chat right now for some
reason here is the link this one here I
mean this one would work too I guess but
this one's HTTPS which is better so I
guess so why not
alright so the links in the chat now so
here we go you can see getting some
activity there so let me know if
anything goes wrong with that I won't be
watching this as I code so if if it
quits working please let me know and
let's check out that error so it did say
it was on line line 24 of the sidebar
item which is right here so that's not
actually before I let me open this back
up if you remember I think yesterday we
were having the problem where when I
switch branches the code wasn't
automatically changing which I'm almost
positive that it did automatically
change before but for some reason it's
not so I'm gonna open that back up again
just to see there we go
now this makes a lot more sense okay so
on line 24 we have this hover color okay
so we see the hover colors here is red
and the hover color down here is a
different color so let's take out this
hover color and that should fix the air
because you know that that makes sense
you shouldn't have to props that have
the same name because that's confusing
all right cool air is fixed there we go
we still have these hairs which I don't
wear these air is coming from it's where
I get these errors all the time in
production or in development but not in
production so not worried about them
right now so now that that works let's
commit that and then merge this branch
into the master branch so I am going to
explain every time I do something on get
our in the command line I'm gonna
explain that for everyone who's not
familiar with it so for those of you who
are familiar with it if it's kind of
annoying that I keep explaining this and
you all know that I'm sorry but I'm
gonna gonna keep doing it because I
think it's better to explain it for the
people that don't know it then than to
not because otherwise they'll be really
lost so we're gonna do git status just
to double-check that we've only changed
the component that we meant to change
and we have in fact only changed that
component and then we're gonna get
commit a.m. and that the a means we're
gonna add everything and we're going to
include the message right in our command
so it'll say remove remove duplicate
props
all right awesome and I'm going to merge
this now
so I've already merged master into that
the other branch and I did the test
there so maybe there's a better way to
do it but I like to do it like that
because that way if if something there's
some weird errors and it breaks a lot of
stuff when I merge it it's only broken
that one branch and I haven't messed up
master so then it's just easier to
switch right back to master instead of
having to worry about trying to roll
back you know to a different version of
it and then it's great because once you
have it right and it's everything's
fixed then you just switch over to
master emerge and everything works so
let's do that so we're gonna go get
merge so when you merge you go to the
branch that you want to merge the other
branch into so I'm in master because I
want to merge something into master I'm
sure there's other ways to do it as well
but this is the way I always do it and
I'm gonna say what branch I want to
merge into my current branch and in this
case I want to merge what did I call
that thinks the only Oberon all right
awesome so you could see we had
obviously no conflicts because that
branch had already merged with master
before or had master merge into it
before so now we'll have double check
make sure everything's working yes it is
working
and
I'm gonna push this so we'll see if
you've never seen how for requests works
basically you you can see the merge
completed right there pretty much
real-time if I go get push origin master
to push it out to get up now it's pushed
there and I can't remember if it
refreshes automatically or if I have to
refresh the page I can't remember let me
try a page refresh basically what should
happen is it should say merged yep there
we go it says merge so I guess you have
not sure if you have to wait for the
Refresh for some reason I thought I'd
seen it just happen automatically before
but maybe I didn't see that maybe I
don't know what I'm talking about
alright so that's another pull request
so thank you for got a lot of pull
requests for this project so far a lot
of really good ones so I really
appreciate that and let me show let me
just throw up on the screen really quick
the contributors so far so here we go
here's our contributors so thank you to
everyone who has contributed and
actually yeah yeah that's everybody ok
okay so let's continue on with our
layout so I think I've decided the way I
want to do this is just run through and
get the base layout for every page and
then I'll go in and work on just the
details yeah I think it would be easier
that way I'll get an idea for when we
reuse things so when I go to handle
changing the styles to make it work I'll
have a better idea of you know if I
change the style globally how it will
affect another page and then otherwise
if I go page by page I might decide to
change so globally and then later on
have to you know edit it and so it could
end up being a bit more messy than it
needs to be in the in the CSS so let's
move on so this page is basically how we
want it with the exception of I mean
obviously this is still lorem ipsum text
and everything but we'll fill that in
logos I'm gonna skip logos for now
because that's gonna be difficult I
don't know it won't be that difficult
it's not like we've never done anything
like that before in react because we
have but it's just gonna be a lot and
since I want to keep it short today I'm
not gonna get into that so the posters
view we got to bring up our the project
as it currently stands the current live
version so we can see what we're but we
need to to build out
all right on my other screen I'm
bringing it up and I'll just pull it
over when it's ready also I am
broadcasting on Instagram so it looks
like that some people watching including
my wife so hey thanks for watching
actually I should I showed my kids one
of the Instagram videos of me doing this
and they were like the baby was just
staring and smiling she was like a mace
that I was in the phone and also sitting
right there that was pretty fun alright
so here's what we have currently live
and this is behind a like a password
[Music]
password protected site so sorry you
can't check this out right now it's not
there's not really anything private in
here that would require having a
password but we just that's how it was
set up so the new one won't require a
password and we're looking at posters
okay so we're just gonna need while this
would be easy so basically the same
thing that we did on the home page
except a different little bit different
organization of the cards so ready go to
2 columns and 3 rows so that's gonna be
super easy we can copy and paste a lot
of what we did for home so I'm gonna
throw foam actually I already have it
over there cool
so we have home on this side so we can
easily copy it and posters there we go
let's bring up posters
so I'm gonna copy all of this
I'm just double-checking okay
all right I'm gonna copy that and we're
just gonna have to change around the
columns a little bit so right now we
need to change all these m fours - we
need them to be M twos and I do want to
change up these rows so we only had two
rows before and now I want three rows so
I'm gonna copy this and we need one two
and then after this second column we're
gonna put in this row we also need to
close out the first row so we're gonna
put a closing div tag all right so now
we've started our row we don't have to
close that because we'll just we're
using the closing div that was in the
other one so we can just delete this row
right one two actually might have to add
another one we can't keep it straight in
my head so we have 1 2 in the first row
and that is properly closed good Row two
one
let's get rid of that yeah okay row two
one two and close it out and then
finally one more one more row and that
is oh that one is already closed out so
this should work but save it and no
error syntax error okay what do we do
okay I probably just forgot to yeah I
didn't copy this stuff at the bottom so
we just need to close that return and
our render now it should work no oh we
didn't I didn't copy that either so we
need to import our components that we're
using so we need to import that from
material UI but save it now now will it
work yeah okay so it works it doesn't
look exactly the one or two but we have
the number of cards that we want so let
me eat you see what's going on here so
I'm even bring over a dev tools so you
can all see what's going on and if
you're checking out the site using the
link that I shared to Endre you could
inspect this as well if you want to all
right so let's see we have a container
the row the columns oh I I know what cuz
I said M - all right I'm sure you all
caught that mistake and I just haven't
looked at the live chat for a while but
my mistake was I put M - in my mind I
was thinking like I wanted it to be half
of the page and so for some reason it
made sense to me that - was somehow half
but really the way it works is that you
need to specify the number of call
you wanted to take up out of 12 columns
so 12 would be full width so I need to
do 6 these are the materialized column
classes so that should work now there we
go now we have what we wanted and all
right so that's it so we're good this
page layout is fine like I said I'm I'm
not gonna worry about this you we can
already see having some sort of you know
padding up here is gonna be necessary
probably for every page so that's why I
wasn't really worried about doing it at
first until we get everything laid out
and then I could see like okay well what
element is gonna be the best to put that
padding on that'll apply everywhere we
need it and if there's somewhere where
we don't need it then we want to make
sure it won't apply there so let's move
on posters letterhead see actually I
just remembered I have my poem adora
timer and I keep forgetting to use it so
put that on there I don't think I
mentioned this yesterday a day before
but somebody made a Pomodoro timer in
Java like a desktop Pomodoro timer and
sent it to me to try out so I haven't
gotten a chance to try it out yet but
maybe I'll try it out and I think I want
to try it out on my laptop and not on my
work computer because well like the IT
department gets a little bit upset about
downloading things so not that I suspect
anything from this app or the guy that
sent me the app but just so that I don't
possibly get in trouble I'm gonna try it
out on my laptop see how it is and maybe
maybe then install it here and show you
all but let's check out what the
letterhead view is supposed to look like
and go back
thank the letterhead oh okay
so it seems like all right not too bad I
have letterhead view is just some text
and then each one of these is a card and
so this is just an image alright so
we'll just import the the cards will
leave the media section of the card we
need the title section and then we need
the the action bar section of the card
so there'll be a little bit different
than the cards that we just used on the
last page but the good news is I mean
none of these are components that are
foreign to material designs so they're
all there they are all available for us
to use so we would probably won't need
to customize too much cool move that to
the side and let's check out this
leatherhead okay
so within letterhead let's create
actually let me bring in let me bring in
what we just did for the posters because
we're gonna we're gonna want rows of two
and since we already have some rows of
two then why not use them so we are
gonna have to change the card
significantly but at least we can keep
all of the the column classes pretty
much as is we'll just delete that last
row so we'll take this row and get rid
of it great and then let's import not
only this will import that we will no
longer need the card text so we'll get
rid of that and then we'll check out the
documentation for material UI and the
cards and we need to add in card actions
and card media
Media and then we're gonna take out card
text we don't need that or actually
let's just do this
put that we'll make that card actions
get rid of all this lorem ipsum there we
go and then let's check out the docs to
see how we need to do this
so within card actions we need to flat
button so let's bring in that flat
button let's see how that looks
yeah that's that's pretty much what we
want so let's bring in the flat button
and then we'll also bring in this action
and we only need one action some only
gonna bring in one of these components
there we go so we have our button the
last thing we need to bring in is this
card media so let's check out how it's
done here so card media let's pull this
and I don't really want the overlay
though how do they do that
not we're not gonna use the overlay but
we are obviously going to have an image
and this image is not gonna work all you
know it's so we don't even have an
images folder so we'll pull in we're
pulling a photo from somewhere else but
we want to place that above the title
oops
and
I should have been doing this all along
there we go
paste that in and I'll copy this as soon
as I remove this stuff so I don't want
oh that's interesting I just want to
want to show you all this because it's
interesting
so the props the overlay prop
we're actually passing in a reactive
component which is cool I don't think
I've ever done that before
so actually passing in another component
with its own props as the props for the
card media I don't know
didn't know you could do that that's
really cool okay so and our image all
right let's see what did we try to use
before that didn't work was it it was
the Bill Murray stock photos didn't work
right I think it was a course issue so
we're not gonna be able to do that
unfortunately I'd love to be able to use
Bill Murray so I think I'm just gonna
use unsplash so we can go to unsplash
and I'm gonna check the proper
dimensions here for that image so what
dimensions are we using 509 by 659 is
that really what dimensions I used 509 I
mean I'm sure it's it's obviously
responsive so it's gonna get bigger or
smaller bucks 600 by 766 was the
original like how do it I had to have
gotten an image like pre-made like that
cuz I can't I don't see how I would have
made an image like that 600 by 776 okay
yeah so let's get an image that's 600 by
776
so I want to get a random image because
that's fun and then you don't get as
bored looking at it and let's pop that
in here and I can't ever remember which
ones with and which ones height for this
alright so this is a two by three so
that must mean two is the height and
three others with all right so the
height was now I can't remember 600 by
770 okay so let's do alright let's let's
try that let's see how this works
oops we're yet
no no it looks like I did some bad copy
and pasting that let's check out what
the problem is
all right that should fix it I should be
good I want to check to make sure our
URL works before I copy it hmm looks
like it didn't that's the problem
that's odd I'm not even there we go
cool you just took a little louder to
come in alright so now that we know that
works we're going to copy this as well
and let's see I don't know it broke
I didn't work last time and break this
you know what I probably yeah I click
the the button to add another one I
still don't know why that would cause it
to be broken but I did add another image
when I need to
ah now I'm getting a Corsair that's
weird that I didn't get one before and
now I'm getting one
let me try let's see can you all see the
images over n drop okay all right cool
I'm saying it now no I don't like how
the random image gives you the same
random image since you're you know
making a call for all of it if you have
it I think if you have the components
like loading in it at different times
you can get them to have different
images I've actually I've done it before
where I'd have it pick a random number
and then use that to grab an image so I
just so that I could get random images
all in the same load but in any case it
doesn't really matter this is only what
we needed to see was just to get the
dimensions
let's move it around just a bit cool all
right
it looks like
yeah we definitely I'm just checking it
again so we definitely have to do
something about the padding in here but
it'll be a little tricky because so we
have proper padding between rows this is
our row break so I'd like to have
consistent padding so it may have to
have some media queries there to make
sure that you know if we're gonna add
padding let's say to each column we want
to make sure we take it away from the
row right now I'm not worried about
adjusting anything the last thing we
need to do is add some text at the top
so it looked like it looked here like we
just had two paragraphs of text so let's
just throw in two paragraphs inside
we're gonna put it inside another row
and then we're gonna have a column a
full width column and then we'll put two
paragraphs into that column and I'm
gonna use I think it was Sarah that
recommended the Bible if some site to
use for lorem ipsum so I think we'd use
Samuel Jackson if some I've used bacon
ipsum before but since this is a
Catholic University I think it would be
better if I use Bible ipsum and I think
the people that I work for would like it
better if I use Bible ipsum as opposed
to Samuel Jackson quotes so hi I just
saw the the first quote that I saw in
Bible if some of my other screen
actually like spells out the one of the
words for God that is to some groups of
Jewish people as actually you're not
really supposed to spell that out or say
it so I'm gonna use a different verse
out of respect for that and not not use
that
oh man I'm seeing it in so many places
why is it giving me this is actually
really weird the the Bible if some
generator is giving me the the same so I
would assume it would give me like
random stuff but it's giving me the same
stuff let's see if I put in two if it'll
be different no it's the same thing
fresh now I want a different quote
am I missing something all right all
right I'll try I will live some a
different day because I don't want to
spend a lot of time on that I mean you
would you would assume that you would
get different Bible clothes right I
might I might have to make my own that
sounds like a good side project oh I'll
make my own because your says what is it
freak out camp has the random quote
generator project so I'm sure there's
some API out there and that you can get
bible quotes from or like scrape the
site or something so let's add in let's
just add in what we know we need and
just generate some lorem ipsum oops
we're gonna do a div with a class name
I'm gonna see cool with the class name
of oops Roe and we also want a div with
the class name of column and then you
wanna make that in s 12 and that means
if you're using materialized
that means on small screens is gonna
take up 12 columns and I wanted always
to take up 12 columns so I'm not gonna
add anything else otherwise you would
add like in this case we added on medium
screens the N we want to only take up 6
out of the 12 columns so be 50% with now
we're gonna add our P tag and eventually
I guess said before I'll probably put in
the float X class but I need to bring
that in for materialized so I'm not
gonna look for it right now but I like
the flow text since I did this site
originally I've read some articles on
proper font size and I'm convinced now
they larger font size is almost always
better for readability so I currently on
newer sites that I'm making I use a much
larger font size than I had previously
and the flow text is a nice response
of font size and make sure that it's a
decent size
all right so I can generate lorem ipsum
whoa that's long string let me
I was hoping there'd be some setting
that I could get to really easily to
wrap that I might have to actually go
into preferences
hmm I thought there was a wrap setting
I'm missing it
why are you editor settings
area
all right so soft rap somebody had
mentioned soft rap in a comment or
something and I think it was I think it
was Nathaniel so anyway yeah see how
much nicer that is thanks to Daniel for
bringing that up maybe I have it maybe
it's on my laptop
but I thought I had that enabled
somewhere but I guess not so just we're
gonna throw in the two paragraphs and
all right cool so that looks looks like
we have the layout that we want yep
obviously we're gonna change change a
little bit we don't need this card
subtitle actually yeah let's take that
out I didn't realize I have the card
subtitle in there oh yeah actually the
more I look at these components from
material UI the more I like them a lot
of these like options are really nice
like things that I would build myself
pretty much every time like adding a
subtitle you know would just add a span
and you know have to set all the
properties to make it look like that
it's really cool that that's built in
but you don't want to subtitle right now
so we're gonna take it out so I'm
thinking that once I once I get the hang
of material UI and really start to learn
how it works I think I will like it all
right cool
so that page is done let's see that was
letter at a share story next is that
next dress here share story
okay so currently for share story what
we have is we actually have a card with
a bunch of text and a four
hmm I'm not exactly sure that I want to
keep this in a card so I'm gonna go I
haven't checked the live chat in a while
so I am gonna check back here but I'm
gonna ask a question first and hopefully
you all can help me when it comes to
material design generally you you don't
use cards in this way right you would if
you have pieces of content you know that
that are gonna be separate and like it's
okay to put those in cars but usually
like in this case I'm essentially using
the card as a container for everything
that's on this page with the exception
of the header so I don't really think
this is the proper way to use it I think
it may be better in this case to simply
put this right on the screen kind of the
paper in the background so I don't know
what do you all think we could try to
put this on the screen over here and see
how it looks
we'll have to bring in we haven't you
worked with any form components yet so
we'll have to bring that in so I think I
think it's worth a try but let me check
the time yeah actually
at this point I'm gonna stop and I'm
gonna go over to the live chat and
that'll probably be all we get in today
so we've done a couple of use the layout
for it the next thing we'll probably do
is bring in some of these components for
forms and I'm at least gonna try out
leaving out the card for this just to
kind of more properly stick to the
material design spec it's when I did
this site I was I was just starting out
with learning material design so I kind
of used cars for everything okay so now
if you were just here for the code part
of it thanks for watching I'm gonna do a
Q&A session now before
I finish up so if you're not interested
in sticking around for the questions and
answers I'll see I'll be back tomorrow
morning with another live stream so if
you can join me then otherwise if you
have a question put it in the live chat
or you can ask me on any social media
thing a lot of people ask me things on
Twitter or you can put it in a comment
on the video so let me scroll up to the
top and I'm just going to get it on
through actually I'm gonna see I'm just
go back down to the bottom just to see
if you all answered my question alright
Rohan says an edge-to-edge card
okay all right John Hanson says I
suggest a story card looks too much like
a modal and so its function looks like a
person would maybe want to dismiss it so
yes resign okay cool I'd know I didn't
think about that but now that you said
it it does kind of look like it could be
a modal cool okay Kevin says I think
with a big enough font and responsive
container it would look just fine on the
paper on the back if you're not sure
what we're talking about like when I say
paper in material design language this
background so behind the card is the
paper right and certain things sit
normally on the paper and this is what I
didn't know when I made this site but
like the print the copy the text here
this font is considered ink okay so ink
goes directly onto a paper it has no
height to it right that's why we don't
put box or we don't put shadows on on
text in material design all right
because it sits on the paper the same
thing like with an image normally an
image sits flat all right that's that's
ink but then if certain things we can
bring out all right look like a card but
it would be better like we don't want to
put everything on the card and it's
weird so it makes it implies almost that
we could move the card out or get rid of
it or there's something behind it so
anyway that I'm no expert on material
design but at least that's my
understanding so if you hear me say
paper I basically just mean the
background that you see I mean you can
see the entire background here so this
is we mean me the paper
okay and Rohan says it feels like the
description text is too large so are you
talking about this text I'm not sure but
anyway yeah this is this text that I
have at the top of these pages might
entirely go away it might end up uh I
think I'd rather go with a really small
header and then move these as to be like
titles to each page so down here we'll
see I'm I want to see how it looks kind
of messed around with it okay so thanks
for your your feedback those good
feedback definitely agree with it so now
I'm gonna go to the top and try to
answer some questions and let's see also
I do have people watching on the
Instagram stream so if you're watching
on Instagram and you're not sure what's
going on I just was doing some live
coding on the free code camp YouTube
channel if you do have a question you
can go join the live chat on there or
you could put it in Instagram and I'll
answer it from there as well
okay so Zack asks what tech does free
code can't challenges use wondering how
hard it is to create your own challenges
on your own site actually that's a good
question I'm not really sure but there
was an article on medium that I just
read earlier today about a company that
actually created their own version of
free code camp so that they could host
code challenges and have it be a little
bit more fair because on free code camp
basically you could you could look up
all the answers they're available so
they totally like clone it all and it's
on github I wish I still had the article
open I closed it out and I had to get
hub repo open right before and I just
closed it out so I don't have the link
ready for you but if you check it out
that the article was something like they
introduced I think it was in was it
Singapore I can't remember for sure but
they'd introduced free code camp to like
thousands of people during the Google
i/o event that they had over there I
think it's in the free code camp medium
page so if you just scroll through there
should be near the top but anyway
that'll give you an idea cuz you can
check out their repo and see what they
did but I don't know a fan I I was not
involved I guess you could just check
out the free code camp repo - I don't
know what I was thinking yeah everything
in free code camp is open source so you
can check out the github repo for that
as well
but I hadn't I was not involved at all
in the making of any of the free code
camp challenges so I I haven't even
submitted any pull request to help out
with that so it would be cool to do so
I've just been as you all know pretty
busy with with the work that I'm doing
right now
roman asks so we are going with v1 alpha
or the the zero times to the other
version so i think i'm gonna stick with
the older version of material UI just
because like what is this day six i had
hoped to be farther along by day six and
i spent a lot more time just trying to
figure out what version we're going to
use and then trying to get the beta
version to work so i don't want to deal
with that anymore i think the other
version is it's way more stable it's
been used by more people there's a much
higher chance of me being able to find
answers to issues that i have and i
don't really have that with a beta
version so it'd be really cool to use
the beta version in the future but i
just i don't think i'm gonna be able to
do it for this project so all the effort
that's put into making the beta version
work by you all by your pull requests is
not going to go to waste because i
really do want to try to use it on a
future project so when that happens i'll
go back and pull out a lot of the the
stuff that was done on that beta branch
that we have for this project now so
that will be helpful in the future but i
just want to kind of let it mature a
little bit before i before i use it
Isaiah says I'm having difficulty
rendering a PDF in a react react
component that's interesting I've never
attempted to render a PDF in a react
component so I'm not really sure that I
could offer you any advice on that right
now but I am really interested in seeing
it so if you have some code on github
where you're trying to do that please
send me a link to that you know you send
me a direct message in Twitter if you
want and I'll try to get to it when I
can the charity truth right now I'm a
little bit behind on getting to the code
and stuff that people want me to review
on on Twitter so if you do send me
something to review I will definitely do
my best to get to it at some point but
there's there's a little bit of a
waiting list right now so don't be
afraid to send it but just if you need
something reviewed like immediately
that's it's probably just not going to
happen
yeah in the the person in the chat with
the with the handle lol lol says when I
said that stream was gonna be sure they
said is it because I'm watching the
stream you make it shorter well not at
all no no it has to be short and I
explained earlier why it has to be short
so I have to I have to get somewhere
it's really important that I that I get
somewhere at this point it's it's a
matter of professional pride that I
figure out what is going on what's going
wrong with my the site that I built and
fix it and I really hope that I can go
there and say no it's the browser it
wasn't me at all that would be the
best-case scenario because then it
wouldn't have been my fault this entire
time but even if it is my fault and
there's some bug that I don't know about
that would still be cool because then at
least I figure it out and and be able to
fix it
okay about halfway through the live chat
now
okay so I see Sebastian saying some
stuff about the the mouse over and stuff
so yeah I'm not sure yes Sebastian sent
me a message on Twitter or something
about that because I'm not exactly sure
what's going on in a live chat and I
know I'm gonna have to stop so I really
don't have time to talk about it right
now because I'm gonna have to end the
stream soon someone that just has the
string so JH k k JH ka says what is card
tag yeah so it's not a standard s it's
not a standard tag right yeah it's no
it's not a standard card it's a it's a
react component it's a custom component
so Sebastian answered that but in case
anyone else was wondering the HTML yet
it it has a lot of non-standard tags so
in my editor these tags are highlighted
a different color than the regular tag
so you'll be able to tell you know that
these are special ones but they're
definitely not not your normal tags they
react components
advanced says you're right it shows up
automatically okay so maybe I just
needed to be more patient and this is in
regard I think to the merge whenever it
displays that your pool request has
actually been merged so I just didn't
wait long enough
maxima is asking what do you what do you
use and and not just to meet everybody
in the stream what do you use to uglify
es6 Jess
okay so John says John Simona says grunt
can trigger glyph i Maxima is using gulp
yeah there's a gulp uglify you'd
probably want to use babel first so i
don't know if anybody said that but yeah
if you want to do es6 i mean if you want
to keep es6 and just uglify your es6 and
not trans pilot I'm not really sure what
you would want to do but if you want to
transpile yes 60s 5 for browser
compatibility and then uglify it then
maybe that's a step you need to put like
in your in your workflow use like I
think there's a gulp Babel so you want
to use gulp babble first trans pilot and
then uglify the code that's been
transpiled so hopefully that makes sense
yeah otherwise I don't really know I
don't really know this babble have
something like that built in I don't
know I'm not sure but it would be
somewhat convenient I guess if it was
alright so the stream on Instagram just
ended so thanks if you're if you wanted
to see my face today you missed it now
but yeah the Instagram stream will be
available for 24 hours
okay Isaiah's asked again about
rendering the PDF in the react component
I'm assuming those before I talked about
how like I honestly really don't know
how to do that but you sent me a link to
your repo I could at least check it out
okay Maxim a said that it was for a note
app so es6 was supported so it didn't
really have to worry about transpiling
so okay
patrick said react inception so I guess
that was when we were I was talking
about passing in a component which I
think I got rid of that but yeah yeah it
is like reacting session
all right Patrick said there's odd
shifting happening to toggle and on
toggle to sidebar and watch the layout
let me check this up
okay I'm not seeing any shifting happen
here maybe I don't know maybe you're
talking with someone else about their
site in the live chat
or possibly it's a different browser and
so I'm not seeing it here
Blake asks what time the stream will be
tomorrow I'm thinking let me think I
have a meeting at 11:30 so maybe around
10:00 Eastern Time maybe it earlier
depends on what time I get into work
tomorrow so I'm not sure but probably at
the latest
I'll start the stream around 10:00 so at
least I can get in like about an hour
before I gotta go to my meeting so
that's that's what I'm thinking so I'll
try to get in early schedule the stream
so you all have a little bit of advance
notice but I don't really have like a
set start time where I have to be here
by sowed it varies depending on like how
many times I had to wake up with my kids
in the middle of the night
Alexander asked Jessie what would you
recommend to improve react skills just
started to use it I would say if you're
like really really beginner at reacting
just starting
check out the react dog the official
react documentation their tutorial some
of it might be kind of too advanced but
you know you'll get a rough idea of
what's going on and then I would I would
use codecademy x' that's like a
browser-based course and that's kind of
a nice introduction as well there's some
YouTube videos that would be helpful so
I think learn code Academy is the
YouTube channel I think they have some
some beginning react videos as well that
can be kind of helpful they're a little
bit dated though so just kind of keep
that in mind like you get a good
understanding of what react is but some
of the syntax there might be better ways
to do it now
and then if you're willing to spend some
money for a course so far the Udacity
react nano degree that I'm taking
currently has been really good so I
recommend that rohan says we need no
update tomorrow what's the issue browser
bug it's a mystery yeah the issues
completely a mystery to me as to why
this isn't working so evidently from
what I can gather just from a ton of
emails and months of trying to figure
out what's happening here is the way it
works it's a password list login so I'm
talking about this meeting that I'm
about to have in a few minutes and it's
not really a meeting it's me gonna I'm
gonna go check out this person's
computer I built a website that has a
password list login system so you enter
your email address and it has to be a
Franciscan dot edu email address you
enter that in and then it sends you an
email with the link you click the link
and you're logged in and it saves your
login into local storage and your
browser
you stay logged in for a year unless
somehow you delete the local storage
when this person clicks the link to log
in it takes them to a blank page at
least that's that's what I've been told
so I want to go check it out now they're
the only reason I can think of that
that's happening is the JavaScript error
early on and so I'm guessing that it's
either javascript is disabled on his
browser for some reason which you would
think would someone would know but I
actually went to somebody else's office
and checked there's their computer out
because a similar thing was happening
and that was the issue JavaScript was
somehow disable they have no idea how it
happened so it could be that or the
issue could be they're using a really
outdated browser so those are my best
guesses right now but I would definitely
fill you in tomorrow on on what I find
out all right Patrick says react PDF
component looks simple haven't used it
but you might take a look at that so
isaiah's was asking about PDFs and
rendering PDFs and react so that's
really cool I didn't even realize that
there was a way to do that
Johnson muda says install another
browser to test that's also the problem
so I don't have access to install
anything on anyone's computers other
than my own because all the computers
are basically on lock my computer's not
on lockdown because I'm a developer and
that doesn't really make sense to lock
my computer down but everybody else on
campus can't install anything or update
anything on their own without IT so I'm
not really gonna even have a chance to
do updates I have to call someone from
the help desk here at the University and
have them do it and I don't know it's
kind of towards the end of the day so
I'm not even sure if that's going to be
reasonable to expect them to be able to
you know update something or install
something for me right away
okay Umberto says check if it is
Internet Explorer check compatibility
mode to make sure they're not running in
compatibility mode okay that's good to
know
I will definitely check that if I need
to Roland says edge is actually good
with standards unlike ie
yeah I agree edge is way better than
Internet Explorer Rowland also says
Safari is worse nowadays yeah I agree
probably my my least favorite browser
that's like a modern browser and I don't
include IE in that anymore since they
came out with edge is definitely Safari
so we had more issues with things not
working in Safari than with pretty much
any other browser
okay so Patrick says I'm not seeing the
issue with the layout on a Mac when it's
strolling because the scrollbar doesn't
change the width so I'll have to check
that out I'll use browser stack to check
it out probably tomorrow so thanks for
that Patrick hopefully that's not gonna
be like a really big issue
okay all right I've gotten to the end of
the live chat and definitely have to
have to get ready and go now but thank
you all for watching and helping out in
the live chat and thank you for all the
contributions and pull requests and
everything I really appreciate that I'll
be back tomorrow probably around 10 a.m.
Eastern Time so different time than
normal but I'll put out a tweet and I'll
schedule it so you should get a
notification through YouTube as well if
you subscribe to this channel so I guess
I'll see you soon
else I'll see you in the morning and
have a great day